Intro
In the world of TV, the key to success is
delivering your product to as many viewers
as possible.
With that in mind, studios usually try to
play things safe – which means it’s even
more shocking to come across a little dirty
humor, especially when it’s embedded in
TV shows made for kids.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 hidden adult jokes
in children’s cartoons.
The New Batman Adventures
In an effort to inspire her boyfriend The
Joker to take the night off work, Harley Quinn
emerges from a giant pie in a 1998 episode
of The New Batman Adventures.
With filling dripping everywhere, she serenades
mister J in her best Marilyn Monroe impression.
If the hidden meaning wasn’t clear enough,
audiences then watch her playfully kick a
cherry at his face, and make a… strange
suggestion.
This scene is pretty sexy to anyone watching,
but not the Joker.
Unimpressed, he tosses Harley outside, and
a whole pie sits wasted.
Rugrats
They say it takes a village to raise a child,
and in the case of Nickelodeon’s Rugrats,
sometimes that means leaving your kids with
their grandpa.
Like any good babysitter would, he does his
best to keep the kids entertained.
He rents them two movies, and picks up one
for himself too.
The title?
“Lonely Space Vixens” Featuring a sexy
alien on the cover, Lou mentions how he plans
to watch this particular title in private,
after the babies go to bed.
Probably a good call, Gramps.
The Flintstones
The famous modern Stone Age family has been
charming their way into our hearts since their
debut in 1960.
Cavemen aren’t renowned for their intellect,
but Barney Rubble is exceptionally slow.
Especially when it comes to anatomy.
During a visit to the costume shop Barney
says he wishes he was taller.
When his pal Fred jokes that he’d need another
head, Barney delivers the punchline.
The two chuckle as a laugh track plays, confirming
that it really was a dirty joke.
Yabba-dabba-gross.
Animaniacs
During an Agatha Christie-inspired episode
of Animaniacs, the three stars are on the
hunt for clues.
After being told to dust for prints, Dot returns
with the singer Prince instead.
Yakko lets her know he meant finger prints
- which his sister once again misunderstands.
The singer seems on board with the idea, but
Dot is still not crazy about it.
It's not even subtle, so how this dirty wordplay
made it to kids is anyone's guess.
Spongebob Squarepants
The most optimistic resident of Bikini Bottom,
Spongebob Squarepants has a squeaky clean
reputation to maintain: as a charismatic,
extroverted, burger-loving sea sponge.
The most mature jokes whizz by at break-neck
speed, leaving the grown-ups giggling, and
the youngsters oblivious.
One such “blink and you’ll miss it”
moment comes care of a dancing sea anemone.
In the privacy of his pineapple, Spongebob
watches the creature flop around on T.V.
We don’t really understand just how much
he was enjoying himself until he’s interrupted
by Gary - proving he was up to some adult
fun.
The Spectacular Spider-Man
A good hair day is a powerful thing.
Just ask Black Cat from The Spectacular Spider-Man.
While dueling Spidey, she dodges the bursts
of web flying through the air.
The scene is full of action as the two dart
around a laboratory, bantering back and forth.
After being shot at with webs, Black Cat utters
a quick line that many viewers didn’t catch
the first time around: “You’d better not
get your goop in my hair.”
It probably doesn't sound like much to a kid,
but parents are sure to notice the quip.
And, depending on experience, will either
laugh or cry.
The Powerpuff Girls
Made in a laboratory by Professor Utonium,
the trio of Blossom, Bubbles, and Buttercup
protect their city using special abilities.
They’re great fighters, but they’re still
kids.
So when a new girl named Robin moves in next
door, they introduce themselves.
During a tour of their house, the girls introduce
Robin to the professor and explain how they
were created by accident in his lab.
With a genuine innocence that only children
possess, Robin replies with a comment that
a kid probably shouldn't be making.
Dexter's Laboratory
This boy genius's life would be perfect if
it weren’t for his psychotic sister Dee
Dee, who's constantly interfering with his
work.
In an episode called “Dee Dee and the Man”
Dexter fires his sister and hires a replacement
- an attractive blonde, who the boy starts
getting more and more interested in.
After leaving to take a cold shower, he even
asks her to dance for him.
Her reply makes it clear that she's not used
to a career in lab assistance.
Looney Tunes
Over its run, The Looney Tunes produced hundreds
of skits.
From romantic skunks to murderous cats, The
Looney Tunes has something for everyone.
When the bloodthirsty, rabbit-hating bandit
Yosemite Sam goes to jail at the hands of
Bugs Bunny, the animators reveal that he’s
about to enter a new romantic relationship…
with his cellmate.
And by the looks of it, it might not be a
consensual one.
Pretty dark stuff for a kids' cartoon.
Rocko's Modern Life
An Australian Wallaby named Rocko moves to
America, and makes some strange new friends,
including a bull named Heffer, who takes up
plenty of odd jobs, even filling in for a
dairy cow.
That job requires Heffer be hooked up to the
Milk-o-Matic milking machine.
Clearly enjoying himself, the scene shows
his eyes rolling, lips quivering, and pupils
turning to stars before he moans and falls
over.
What was going on behind that fence?
You be the judge.
Keep in mind, he makes sure to say goodbye
to the Milk-o-Matic before he leaves, too.
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite adult jokes
from children’s cartoons?
Tell us about them in the comments below.
If you liked this video you might also like
10 Hidden Adult Jokes in Children’s Movies!
Click on the link on the top right and don’t
forget to subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more videos like this one.
Thanks!